screaming my coffee and rock and roll
peralta ah captain holt you look very
sad i can never tell don't you have a
murder suspected question he is in the
interrogation room as we speak sitting
and i assume stewing i put on a song
that i think sums up his situation
nicely
[Music]
because you see you got him babe i
understood the word play yes
i've been chasing this guy for three
months i've got him dead to rights
fingerprints witnesses it's in the bag
so i'm just gonna grab a healthy
breakfast are those gummy bears wrapped
in a fruit roll-up
breakfast burrito but yeah i pity your
dentist ah joke's on you i don't have a
dentist
oh this can't be good major crimes
division just called they're taking over
your murder case the vulture is on his
way here now no
doesn't that guy get tired of stealing
our cases he took one for me and rosa
last week
oh you made us run up ten flights of
stairs it's over
thanks guys
i got it from here
don't worry we can stall him until you
get the confession we rehearse this you
guys this isn't a drill everyone know
their assignments all right hands in
commence operation broken feather and go
okay guess
i don't have a lot of time i need your
full signed confession we have four
minutes we can do this but i'm not
guilty listen to me gus
we can do this son
[Music]
yo
is this a police station or a toilet
because all i see is turds
attack the pembroke
[Music]
oh no i spilled coffee on you by
accident
lucky for you this wipes off quickly
this coast made out of whale skin
the vulture still flies the vulture
still flies
hey pembroke what do you say we go talk
about a case in the break room oh yeah
what case is that the case of how you
got so damn sexy god owed me a favor
okay so
i told you i didn't know the guy you're
lying we have pictures of youtube come
on we only have three minutes it's like
you're not even trying to confess the
votes aren't coming we need more time
someone do something i got it
tear gas
all right fine
i'll just go then
with this fully signed confession we did
it guess whoa
suck it vulture i killed that guy and
his neighbor but you were too late
wait you killed his neighbor how do you
think you're getting out of this figgis
do you even have a plan i'm gonna hold
you hostage to get away then i'm gonna
drive to a gas station while still a
clean car then headed for the airport
where i'll buy it take out my false id
then kill you in the parking lot and
disappear again
you're scrambling
look i told you we're nypd yeah right i
can prove it look up brooklyn detective
attacked by birds you'll see an article
with a photo of me
all available i'm gonna give you a
window and you're gonna go after jake my
name is detective rosa diaz nypd get
back i'm reaching for my badge
[Music]
keep walking
let him go
put that gun down or he dies he's not
gonna shoot me he needs me alive to get
out of here yeah you willing to take
that bet i wouldn't
now put the gun down
oh
you shot him oh
god
are you okay i'm sorry i shot you i
thought that's what the nod meant it was
it was awesome it was actually just like
the end of speed which is a pretty good
movie it's not as good as i are tired
okay jake i'm gonna go after your
biggest yeah i was gonna say you should
keep going after figgis same page still
get out of the car
[Music]
[Applause]
freeze punk yeah freeze punk tina where
did you get that gun lost and found at
the storage facility they have boxes of
them they're everywhere peralta
what do you have to say for yourself the
whole nypd knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now okay
thanks for the tip let's kill them both
get out of here before the cops come
wait no no no no i was lying about the
backup i came alone titled my sex tape
doesn't matter
you're both gonna die now
better get some corticosteroids to treat
that laryngeal fracture sorry i couldn't
bring myself to call him a dirt bag and
why would you a dirtbag is a very useful
part of the vacuum cleaner clearly it's
a compliment oh you guys are so perfect
for each other
oh wow that's good stuff who's your guy
actually it's a woman women can be drug
dealers too hashtag i'm with her here oh
no i'm good not to be snobby but
i got my own stash it's the bomb
smuggled this violin on a plane stuck it
right up my butt
want some no thanks i'm good with the
non-butt coke suit yourself
bartender may be my favorite drink it's
called a bottle of whiskey i like your
style you know when i first met you two
i thought you're pretty uptight more
like down loose that's nothing hey uh
about the interrogation room don't even
worry about it sometimes you gotta do
stuff me my crew sometimes we gotta do
stuff too i understood and hey look if
you ever need help doing stuff
maybe keep us in mind i will enough
business huh
[Music]
[Applause]
wakey wakey rise and shine it's go time
go time what time go time i said i'd
keep you in mind remember well we got a
job good job we're robbing a bank we
always party the night before keeps us
loose
hear your masks
oh great
awesome obviously we're on board just
one thing if rosa doesn't eat breakfast
she's a real bear plus i should go home
take a shower and gots to watch my
michael and kelly
we go now sure totally groban's filling
in anyway let's go rob a bank
hello chunk
heard you want your sperm you're gonna
have to go through me oh no this is way
worse than the male thing what male
thing nothing there's no male thing
there's no male thing but it's my sperm
how did you even find out i wanted it
because it counts under my name storage
facility called me saying that you were
looking to make a withdrawal so i went
ahead and withdrew it for you
i have all of your sperm but you don't
even care about it eleanor
i mean remember oh hey charles i'll
never have a baby with you because i
don't love you and a child's not gonna
fix that oof when we started doing the
silly voice i thought it was gonna be
more fun but it wasn't i do not want
your dna i want something else i hit
some dumb ass with my car now he's suing
me
what i want is for you to use your badge
and your gun to intimidate him into
dropping the case wow that is
so very illegal he's not doing that i
don't care you have 48 hours
to do so or i'm gonna take your sperm
and i'm gonna dump it into the east
river please don't do that and there
will never be the possibility
of a little pie-faced
charles boyle jr proud of it it's me
madeline thank you for coming raymond
always a pleasure to call on a
vanquished foe i feel like jackie joyner
kersey congratulating one of the other
slower runners buckle up it's gonna be a
hell of a ride get us it i'm sure you'd
like to take some weight off your
clothing hubs calling me the devil how
original raymond actually i was calling
you a goat you goat
i'd like to talk about my promotion very
well but first how do i know you're not
wearing a wire
i need to pat you down
if you must
what is going on
i'm watching something ah sir there you
are we've been looking everywhere kevin
said he hasn't heard from you all night
yes i've been sitting in my office
wallowing in my hopelessness and eating
the saddest food known to mankind
ice cream oh my god he's bridgette jones
okay well it's time to put that aside
and pull out whatever food you eat when
you're happy dry beans sure look we can
still stop john kelly all we need is
some hard evidence oh he won't let us
anywhere near him or one belize plaza i
know which is why i've assembled a team
of powerful allies in the nypd no that's
too risky how do you know they're not
loyal to john kelly because these people
aren't loyal to anybody
[Music]
i made a suicide squad
you